Parece difícil, complicado, casi imposible
de creer - dadas las circunstancias - pero
hubo una época hace no mucho tiempo en la
que Venezuela fue la envidia de toda Latinoamérica.
Queridos amigos, en este canal, aquí en VisualPolitik,
os hemos hablado mucho de la Venezuela de
hoy: os hemos contado qué está ocurriendo,
porque está ocurriendo e, incluso, algunas
de las cosas que pueden pasar.
Y creo que hoy todos, salvo tal vez Íñigo
Errejón tenemos muy claro qué es lo que
está pasando:
Lo cierto es que tras casi 20 años de Revolución
Bolivariana, Venezuela es un país destrozado,
un país que sufre una brutal crisis económica,
la falta de alimentos y medicinas y una inseguridad
galopante.
Algo que, lógicamente ha provocado que millones
de venezolanos se hayan marchado en busca
de una vida mejor.
Venezuela atraviesa ni más ni menos que una
enorme crisis humanitaria.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, porque esto
no siempre fue así. Como os he dicho, hubo
una época hace no tanto tiempo en la que
Venezuela era un país próspero, un país
al que muchas personas emigraban en busca
de oportunidades.
¿Queréis conocer mejor esta otra historia?
Pues atentos.
(LA VENEZUELA PRÓSPERA)
Bueno, como seguro ya todos sabéis Venezuela
tiene las mayores reservas conocidas de petróleo
convencional de todo el planeta.
Hablamos de más de 300.000 millones de barriles
de petroleo.
[Sí, sí, de mejor o peor calidad, Venezuela
tiene más petróleo que toda Rusia o Arabia
Saudita.]
Y no solo petróleo… también otros muchos,
muchísimos recursos naturales.
("Venezuela es un país muy rico que tiene
de todo: hierro, petróleo, oro, diamantes,
gas. Y una banda de delincuentes los tomó.
“El Puma Rodriguez”)
Pues bien, el caso es que hubo un tiempo donde
los venezolanos sí que supieron sacar partido
a toda esta inmensa fortuna.
Me estoy refiriendo a la década de los 70.
Veréis, en aquel momento las cosas en Venezuela
iban.. ¿Cómo decirlo?.. En términos marineros,
viento en popa y a toda vela.
Iban tan bien las cosas que esta frase utilizada
por muchos venezolanos en muchas tiendas,
especialmente cuando viajaban al extranjero,
se convirtió casi en el emblema nacional:
[ ¡dame dos!]
Y es que, amigos, en
aquellos años había dinero y lo que es más
importante, se ganaba dinero.
(De esta forma es como surgió una pujante
clase media, el desempleo era de apenas el
4% y cada año se construían miles y miles
de kilómetros de nuevas carreteras.
La pobreza, que hoy afecta a 9 de cada 10
venezolanos, no superaba el 20%.)
Eran tiempos felices. Había tantos excesos,
que, por ejemplo, viajar a Miami se convirtió
en algo habitual entre la clase media,
Y, ¿Sabéis dónde estaban los mejores y
más caros restaurantes franceses de toda
la región? 1,2 3…..Correcto, en Caracas.
Y aún más, los venezolanos, ojo, se convirtieron
ni más ni menos que en los mayores consumidores
de Whisky de todo el mundo.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien. En aquellos años
parecía que este país iba a comerse el mundo.
[Ya sabéis: ¡dame dos!]
(De hecho, por aquel entonces - a diferencia
de lo que ocurre hoy - Venezuela se convirtió
en toda una Meca para miles y miles de inmigrantes
latinoamericanos. Todo el mundo quería experimentar
la prosperidad venezolana.
Incluso, gracias a un sistema democrático
que funcionaba, Venezuela se convirtió también
en un refugio para muchos exiliados procedentes
del Chile de Pinochet o de la Argentina de
las Juntas militares.)
Sin embargo, amigos, es evidente que un buen
día toda esta bonanza se termino.
Así que las dos preguntas que podemos hacernos
son: ¿Cómo logró Venezuela ser un país
tan próspero? Y la segunda, ¿Por qué se
terminó todo?
Bien, veámoslo.
(PETROVENEZUELA)
Gracias a los recursos naturales,
a unas instituciones que más o menos funcionaban
- aunque no fuera Suiza -
y a una población relativamente bien formada,
Venezuela fue tradicionalmente uno de los
países más prósperos de América Latina.
(“Venezuela era tan rica como Noruega en
los 60”. El Español)
Sin embargo, lo que ocurrió a principios
de los años 70 fue mucho más allá.
Os hago una pregunta, ¿Os suena de algo el
año de 1973?
En Octubre de ese año los países árabes
pertenecientes a la OPEP, a la Organización
de Países Exportadores de Petróleo, decidieron
castigar a los países que habían apoyado
a Israel en la guerra del Yom Kipur.
[Bueno, esta al menos fue la excusa oficial.
Pero también es cierto que estos países
llevaban años negociando con las compañías
de petróleo una fórmula para incrementar
los ingresos de estos países y que las negociaciones
no llegaron a ninguna parte.]
El caso es que ¿Sabéis qué se les ocurrió
hacer? Ni más ni menos que bloquear sus exportaciones
de petróleo a todos aquellos países que
hubieran apoyado a Israel. Eso incluía a
Estados Unidos y a gran parte de la Europa
occidental.
(Para que nos entendemos, esta acción fue
equivalente a un gran recorte en la producción
mundial de petróleo. Un recorte que prácticamente
de la noche a la mañana golpeó al mercado
mundial con una fuerza descomunal.
El efecto fue inmediato. En poco tiempo el
precio del barril de petróleo pasó de aproximadamente
1,60$ a casi 10$. De la noche a la mañana,
los países productores de petróleo eran
ricos, ricos de verdad.)
Y ya lo sabéis, en Venezuela otra cosa no,
pero petroleo hay todo el que quieras.
[Bueno, ahora hay petróleo pero el gobierno
de Maduro no es capaz de extraerlo, con lo
cual es como si no lo hubiera…¿no?]
El caso es que este país fue uno de los grandes
beneficiados de la crisis del petróleo de
1973.
De repente no solo se había incrementado
el precio sino que, además, todas las potencias
occidentales se pegaban por el petróleo venezolano.
Con el bloqueo había quedado claro que Venezuela
era un proveedor mucho, muchísimo más seguro.
(De esta forma, Los petrodólares empezaron
a llover como si no hubiera mañana y en 1975,
el presidente Carlos Andrés Perez decidió
nacionalizar todo el petróleo y crear PDVSA.
Desde ese momento la inmensa mayor parte de
la lluvia de petrodólares fue a parar a las
arcas del estado… que, por supuesto, también
empezó a gastar como si no hubiera mañana.
Fueron los años locos de Venezuela.
En 1977 la renta per capita venezolana practicante
duplicaba la del resto de América Latina.
Caracas era una ciudad en ebullición, repleta
de construcciones y proyectos por todas partes.)
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento. Cómo
veis toda esta bonanza tuvo como causa fundamental
la enorme cantidad de petrodólares que empezaron
a llover sobre Venezuela.
(“Venezuela fue un país muy exitoso precisamente
por la renta petrolera hasta los años 70.
Esa renta le permitió al país financiar
la modernización de los servicios”, recuerda
Humberto García Larralde.)
Cuando un gobierno empieza a recibir tanto
dinero de repente, tiene dos opciones: o gastarlo
como si no hubiera mañana o invertirlo de
forma seria y utilizarlo para impulsar la
economía nacional.
La pregunta es, ¿Qué pensáis que hizo el
gobierno de Venezuela?
Atentos
(EL FIN DEL SUEÑO)
Con toda la lluvia de dinero que produjo el
petróleo, el Presidente de Venezuela, Carlos
Andrés pÉREZ prometió que el país se desarrollaría
completamente en pocos años.
Pregunta: ¿Adivináis qué estrategia utilizó?
Fijaos.
(Con el dinero del petróleo se puso en marcha
una política que apostó por cerrar la economía
venezolana, poner elevados aranceles y restringir
la competencia para así desarrollar una industria
local que fuera capaz de sustituir las importaciones.)
[Vamos, lo que vino a ser la Política de
Sustitución de Importaciones típica de América
Latina y que tan bien conocida es por los
argentinos.]
(Junto a ello, el incremento del gasto público
que no dejó de crecer como la espuma y los
subsidios pagados con los petrodólares - ya
sabéis, había que ganar elecciones - serían
el camino al desarrollo.)
El resultado de todo ello, amigos, es que
en poco tiempo hacer negocios con el estado
o tener un trato de favor por parte del gobierno
se convirtió en la actividad más lucrativa
de todo el país. Y eso es algo que siempre
conlleva tres problemas:
Primero la corrupción se dispara. Claro si
la forma de hacer dinero es influir en la
voluntad de un político o un funcionario…
al final siempre aparecen
los sobres.
Segundo, cuando el estado es la mayor fuente
de oportunidades y negocios, las empresas
se especializan en producir no para los consumidores
ni para el resto del mundo, sino en producir
para el estado.
Y de la misma forma las empresas que viven
de tener el favor del gobierno y restringida
la competencia tampoco son las más innovadoras
ni las más eficientes.
Al final generas un sistema económico dependiente
y poco productivo.
Y tercero, todo esto implica que el gobierno
no pueda parar de gastar. De una forma y otra
todo se levanta sobre el dinero público.
Al final nunca queda ni un centavo y sí muchas
deudas.
Pues bien, eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió
en Venezuela.
Cuando en la década de los 80 el precio del
petróleo empezó a bajar… todo la prosperidad
venezolana empezó también a venirse abajo.
(En 1983, cuando se produce el llamado viernes
negro el 18 febrero, el bolívar se vino abajo
respecto al dólar. Fue un primer aviso.
Pero el gobierno hizo caso omiso… siguió
con sus planes, gastando a lo loco y favoreciendo
a los amiguetes del poder. En 1989 la cosa
no dio más de sí y la economía venezolana
sufrió una enorme crisis.)
Fue entonces cuando se produjo el llamado
“Caracazo”, una oleada de protestas contra
el gobierno que derivó en saqueos y enfrentamientos
con las fuerzas de seguridad del estado que
no dudaron en utilizar la fuerza de una forma
totalmente indiscriminada.
El saldo pone los pelos de punta, según los
datos oficiales 276 vidas perdidas, algunos
datos extraoficiales hablan de cerca de 3.000.
Venezuela había comenzado su carrera hacia
el abismo.
En fin amigos, como veis, la fortuna de los
recursos naturales puede convertirse con malos
gobiernos en la peor de las pesadillas. Venezuela
tuvo la oportunidad de convertirse en un país
muy rico, desgraciadamente no cogió el tren
y hoy ya conocemos el resultado.
Si te ha resultado interesante este vídeo
no olvides darle a like y suscribiere a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.